the ga of ibm cloud code engine division
managed database as a service
and a new way to control your data in
the security and compliance center
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all
my name is ian and i am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements from ibm cloud
you guys have heard me talk about ibm
cloud code engine in previous episodes
and i'm really excited to announce that
the service is now generally available
code engine is a fully managed runtime
where you can go live in seconds without
having to
size deploy secure manage or
decommission
any underlying infrastructure code
engine will take care of scaling your
containers
applications or batch jobs and you'll
only pay for what you actually use
if you don't have an image code engine
will build one for you from your git
repo
the build process is automated and you
choose whether to use a docker file or a
cloud native build pack
best of all code engine gives you a
unified user experience
regardless of the type of workloads you
deploy that means you can run your
containers
applications source code or batch jobs
in a single environment
and they all share a secure private
network within code engine
to learn more about how to get started
with ibm cloud code engine check out the
link i've got in the description
of this video next up i'm excited to
introduce digion managed desktop as a
service on ibm cloud
digioncloud desktops deliver
high-performing end-user computing
environments
from 43 ibm cloud data centers across
the globe
automated deployment of an optimized
architecture removes the headache of
infrastructure planning
and the turnkey managed service provides
worry-free desktops that perform at
scale
you can be confident in the solution too
because layered security keeps your
company data
secure and protected these plus a number
of other features that are covered in
the blog
mean that digion cloud desktops are
ideal for move to cloud
burst scenarios backup and disaster
recovery and bulk ads for mergers or
acquisitions
to learn more check out the link below
to wrap things up today we're taking
another step forward in our mission to
help you achieve continuous security and
compliance by giving you more control
over the privacy of your data
many organizations have to meet policies
and controls that ensure that they are
abiding by regulatory compliance
obligations
with the ibm cloud security and
compliance center you can ensure that
you're meeting the data privacy
requirements
set by governments and institutions by
controlling the location in which your
data is stored and processed
when you work with the security and
compliance center data is gathered or
generated when your resources are
scanned
the data can be configuration data or
results data
by default that data is stored and
processed in the united states
but now if your organization needs to
address specific geographical data
privacy requirements
you can change the location to either
the united kingdom or the european union
through a simple process in the ui for
more info on the security and compliance
center
hit the link below thanks so much for
joining me today for this episode of ibm
cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you